when was the last time a bird pooped on
you well apparently you have a better
chance of winning the lottery than you
do of getting pooped on by a bird which
is why some cultures consider this
unexpected unpleasant occurrence to be
good left but there's nothing lucky
about this look at the sky it's not a
bird or a plane it's a pterodactyl they
never went extinct and you have to deal
with them but how
if pterodactyls never went extinct would
we consider them to be food friends or a
new way to get around this is what if
and here's what would happen if
pterodactyls were still alive first
things first pterodactyls are properly
referred to as pterosaurs
but they're not technically dinosaurs
pterosaurs are giant winged reptiles and
there are several different species of
them in all sorts of shapes and sizes of
course no human has ever seen a
pterosaurs since they went extinct about
66 million years ago which is way before
humans showed up but from old bones and
fossilized remains we can get an idea of
what it might have been like to live
alongside these giant flying things or
do we even want to know
pterosaurs how big were they and what
would we do with them because you know
that humans can't just leave an exotic
creature to do whatever it wants on its
own
what do we keep them as pets or farm
them for meat or would we leave our
bikes and cars in the garage and simply
fly to work it's not as easy as that
some pterosaurs like Quetzalcoatlus
northrop i could be as tall as giraffes
with wings that stretched 11 meters wide
but you might be able to keep this
little guy in your home nemi kilometer
as cryptic us was one of the smallest
pterosaurs with a wingspan less than 25
centimeters that's probably how it got
its name which means hidden flying
forest dweller
but if keeping pterosaurs as pets is
either too dangerous for you or simply
too impractical why don't we find out
how they taste well I hope you don't
have a big appetite because despite
their size pterosaurs don't offer much
meat aside from their huge wingspan
their legs arms and torsos are tiny so
it would definitely not be worth the
cost and effort of raising a pterosaur
for food maybe we could ride them once a
theme-park ride is now a reality you
could ride the pterosaur if they were
still alive today but the flight
wouldn't be as majestic as you might
imagine first of all they wouldn't be
able to carry just anyone with the
largest pterosaurs weighing an estimated
180 to 250 kilograms they could probably
only comfortably lift and carry smaller
people but I don't know would you let
your kid on one of these things once
airborne you wouldn't be flying for very
long until it would be time to touch
down again like modern birds and bats
pterosaurs would cover long distances by
soaring rather than constantly flapping
their wings after taking off they would
flap their wings to gain altitude and
upon reaching a sufficient height they
simply glide until they needed to get
higher or felt like landing for a rest
but with your extra weight on their back
they probably wouldn't be able to glide
for very long
not to mention that it probably wouldn't
be a very comfortable ride because it
would be incredibly cold and hard to
breathe at the higher altitudes so maybe
it's for the best that we never lived
with pterosaurs they probably weren't as
menacing as the movies make them out to
be but I don't think anyone would want
to be showered with their good luck
either now if you think that's worrying
can you imagine how scary it would be if
dinosaurs never went extinct well that's
a story for another what-if